uh welcome so much to standardize your
research data with the NIH common data
elements Repository
the purpose of today's training is to
familiarize you with common data
elements or cdes and the NIH common data
elements repository or the cver
I'm Catherine thaley from the National
Library of medicine's office of
Engagement and training and here with me
today are my colleagues Brittany Davis
Kate Majewski and Mike Davidson also
from the office of Engagement and
training and we are joined by Robin
Taylor from the nlm's medlars management
section who will be helping me to answer
your questions
Robin has been with MMS for over three
years as a technical Information
Specialist and is the product lead for
the cder
during today's training you'll have the
opportunity to ask questions and
practice searching in the Repository
to keep us on track we're providing a
handout that you can download and follow
along with and Kate is putting a link to
the handout in the chat now
if you're working on a small screen and
it's not feasible for you to work on a
handout during the presentation feel
free to just listen along and we'll
share a link to the answer key at the
end of class which you can then use to
review
we do have everyone muted to cut down on
background noise so a couple of notes
about how we'll be communicating in Zoom
today
if you have a question or a comment
please use the chat box and send it to
everyone
I will not be able to answer messages
that are sent directly to me
Brittany is going to be monitoring your
chat questions throughout and I will
pause frequently to see if there's
anything that I or Robin need to address
during class I will also be occasionally
asking for your non-verbal feedback
using the reactions feature and the
reactions feature is accessible from the
reactions button at the bottom of your
screen so please find that button now
and give me a thumbs up to indicate that
you found it
you can see lots of thumbs up thank you
some devices may not allow that type of
interaction and that's totally okay if
you can't find the reactions button on
your device please feel free to use chat
to respond when I ask you to and thank
you for all those thumbs up
okay I'm now going to turn off my camera
and we will jump in
today we'll explore a variety of ways
that cdes and the repository can support
you and your work but to get us started
I want to put them in the context of the
nih's mission
both the nlm and NIH have identified
common data elements as a tool for
facilitating the interoperability of
data
ensuring that biomedical research is
interoperable is a step towards making
that data Fair
the fair principles recommend that data
be findable accessible interoperable and
reusable
and the repository is one way that NIH
supports researchers in aligning with
the fair principles
additionally in the nlm Strategic plan
for
2017-2027 cdes support the objective to
connect the resources of a digital
research Enterprise
in the NIH strategic plan for data
science the use of cdes is encouraged to
improve accuracy consistency and
interoperability among data sets within
various health and disease research
and finally you're probably aware of the
new NIH data management and sharing
policy that goes into effect in January
2023 common data elements can be a part
of a compliant plan
so if you would like to learn more about
that policy Kate is sharing a link to
the NIH scientific data sharing office
website in the chat
if you know how to locate cdes in the
cder you'll be better equipped to
support all of these goals
all that being said
today's training is going to
specifically focus on how to navigate
the repository and find cdes that will
assist you with your data collection
process and this is the agenda for today
first we'll review what you need to know
before using the repository like what a
CDE is and special repository features
that will age your searching
then I'll demonstrate the cder live for
you and you'll have the opportunity to
practice on your own too
and finally we'll review how to save
cdes for later and how to get help if
you're stuck
but before all of that I would like to
get a sense of Who You Are in your work
some of you already said hello in the
chat so thank you for that
um please take a moment to tell us in
the chat your title or your role and the
name of the organization that you're
with
wonderful I'm seeing a mix of
organizations that folks are coming from
and your different roles
great
great thank you for sharing where you're
coming from and what your role is
um next I would like to know what your
comfort level is with using CDs
so please enter in the chat uh the
letter that corresponds to your response
and your answer options are a very
comfortable I use them all the time be
kind of comfortable I've used them
before but it was a challenge
see somewhat uncomfortable I've
attempted to use them but it wasn't
successful
D I know what cdes are but I've never
used them or E I don't even know what
cdes are and that's okay if you don't
we're going to go over that together
and I see our responses coming in
looks like we have quite a mix I'm
seeing a lot of these so many folks may
be familiar with cdes but haven't used
them before
excellent thank you for those responses
so we can actually use the data that you
just provided to explore some reasons
that you might consider using cdes in
your projects
let's say that I'm writing a report
after this training to summarize how it
went and I want to include some data
about you the participants
I could start by entering each of your
answers in a spreadsheet and then I
might need to standardize your
organization's name and how it's
represented
for example do I write out the name as
in the National Library of Medicine
do I use the acronym of nlm or maybe
both with the acronym in parentheses
beside the name
this is just a small set of data so it
wouldn't take me too long to standardize
but what if I wanted to compare the
responses from all nlm trainings not
just this one
with more data it could take a lot
longer to standardize and I would have
to ask other trainers to standardize
their data too so that we could combine
our results
plus what if another trainer asks about
their audience's comfort level with cdes
but they asked the question in a
different way so for example maybe they
asked the audience to describe their
level of comfort in their own words it
would be really hard to compare those
free text responses to the responses
that you just provided we would have two
very different sets of data like the
ones on the slide
if my colleagues and I came together and
created a survey that asked all of our
participants to answer questions using
the same format we would be able to
combine and compare our data quickly and
efficiently we would have results sooner
and we could adapt our trainings a lot
faster based on who participates
and you probably want to compare your
research results to those of your
colleagues who are studying similar
topics
cdes can help you do that
foreign
so as we just saw some of us are very
familiar with common data elements and
the repository and for others it's a
brand new topic so let's review a
definition of CDE so that we're all on
the same page
and this definition is the answer to the
first question on your handout
common data elements or cdes are
standardized precisely defined questions
paired with a set of specific allowable
responses used systematically across
different sites studies or clinical
trials to ensure consistent data
collection
in other words it's a standardized way
of collecting a particular piece of
information from a respondent no matter
who is asking the question it's asked in
the same way and respondents have the
exact same answers to choose from
this applies to when respondents are
filling out their own answers or if the
researcher is recording the answers on
their behalf
so let's look at an example of a CDE
together
on this slide is a CDE from the
Repository
it's titled usual place of healthcare
type
and it asks is there a place that you
usually go to when you are sick or need
advice about your health
select all that apply
that is the standardized precisely
defined question of the CDE
respondents can answer with one of these
specific allowable options
a doctor's office or Community Health
Center
Walk-In Clinic
Urgent Care Center or retail clinic in a
pharmacy or grocery store
emergency room
a VA Medical Center or VA Outpatient
Clinic
some other place there is no place
don't know refused or not reported or
unknown
here's another example of a CDE and this
one is titled date of chest examination
it asks what was the date of the Imaging
examination
the specific allowable response for this
one is the date and you'll see other CDs
fees in the repository that allow
responses like the time a number or a
date
so after viewing those two examples you
might be thinking about how cdes can fit
into your workflow
first cdes can save resources including
your time and your labor rather than
writing your own instrument or data
collection tool you can find one in the
Repository
using cdes also advances science because
it allows researchers to compare data
and results across studies
imagine if you could seamlessly compare
your results with researchers across
other institutions without having to
coordinate your efforts because you're
both already using cdes
or you might be required to use cdes to
comply with organizational policies or
your assisting researchers at your
institution with writing a data
management and sharing plan for a grant
many Grants awarded by the NIH now
require or strongly encourage the use of
cdes so the repository can help you to
meet that requirement
take the case of the Cure Sickle Cell
initiative from the national heart lung
and Blood Institute which uses cdes for
all three of these reasons
the initiative's goal is to accelerate
the development of Gene therapies for
sickle cell disease
they're collecting information from
those living with sickle cell disease
about their attitudes towards clinical
trials
to do this they developed a set of cdes
for any researcher working on this
project
with these cdes already available this
gets the research off the ground faster
this map on the slide illustrates where
that data collection has already taken
place and because they're using cdes
researchers across the country can
combine their data easily regardless of
where it was collected from
additionally their investigators are
strongly encouraged to use cdes if
they've been awarded a grant from the
nhlbi
the focus of our training today the NIH
CDE repository for c-ber was developed
to help you find cdes
it was designed to provide researchers
with cdes that have been recommended or
acquired by NIH institutes and centers
or other organizations for use in
research and for other purposes
the NIH CDE governance committee reviews
and assesses cdes submitted by ICS and
they work closely with the NIH CBE
repository team at the nlm
currently a repository has over 29 000
cdes from across 18 different
organizations and initiatives
in the next part of this training I'm
going to highlight two key features of
the repository that can assist you with
your search
NIH endorsed cdes and forms and this
will prepare you to actually search in
the repository in a few minutes
the repository includes NIH endorsed and
non-nih endorsed cdes
NIH endorsed cdes have been reviewed and
approved by an expert panel and they
meet established criteria and this is
the answer to number two on your handout
so I'll repeat it NIH endorsed cdes have
been reviewed and approved by an expert
panel and meet established criteria
this is a new feature that is intended
to help you identify cves that are ready
to use
NIH recognized bodies like institutes or
research initiatives May submit cdes to
the nihcde governance committee for
consideration for endorsement
when the governance committee deems the
cdes endorsed the nlm will publish the
cdes in the repository and designate
them as NIH endorsed
okay on this slide is the criteria for
endorsed cdes and these are also number
three on your handouts so you can follow
along there too
this criteria was developed by the NIH
scientific data Council
the criteria includes clear definition
of variable measure with prompt and
response
documented evidence of reliability and
validity
human and machine readable format
preferred
recommended or designated by a
recognized NIH body
and Licensing and IP status clear
the expectation is that the designation
of cdes as being endorsed by the NIH and
making those cdes discoverable and
accessible through the repository will
advance the use of cdes and NIH
supported and conducted research
so for you this means that you can more
quickly identify the cdes that have met
the set of criteria and are ready to use
if a CDE is endorsed you'll see this
gold ribbon icon in the Repository
you can search directly in the NIH
endorsed CDE collection or you can limit
your search results to endorsed cdes in
the repository which we'll see how to do
in a few minutes
not all cdes in the repository are
endorsed at least not yet so when we
start working in the repository today
I'll point out some other ways that you
can sort through your options
the second repository feature I want to
highlight is forms
sometimes cdes are combined to create
forms in the Repository
forms are a group of questions or
variables with specified sets of
allowable responses that are used as a
set for particular researcher clinical
reasons and this is the answer to number
four on your handout so I'll say it
again forms are a group of questions or
variables with specified sets of
allowable responses that are used as a
set for particular research or clinical
reasons
forms can collect a lot of data about a
participant all at once like a family
history or they might assess something
like pain or the severity of an adverse
effect from a medication or procedure
forms will often include a system for
scoring a participant's responses
once they've completed filling out or
responding to a form's questions the
administrator will tally up their score
and different scores will lead to
different conclusions or interventions
nope
here we go went too far so some
repository forms recreate validated
instruments that were created outside of
the repository so for example this audit
C questionnaire is intended to identify
alcohol use disorders and it was
developed by the World Health
Organization in 1998 but it's now
available in the repository and it
includes three CDs
other forms were created in the
repository this includes a form like the
brics social determinants of Health from
the ninr which the audit C questionnaire
that we just saw is actually
incorporated into
this form is a collection of 63 cdes
related to social determinants of Health
and in addition to the audit C
questionnaire it also includes cdes
about access to care food security
depression housing and other topics
so the key thing to remember about forms
is that they are composed of individual
cdes
and those cdes come together to measure
or assess something
and because the repository has both
individual cdes and forms that means
that there are more options for finding
the data collection tool that you need
okay
there we go I'm having some a sticky
mouse here with my slides all right so
now you're ready to search the
repository uh before we dive in I do
want to review what we've covered so far
so Britney is going to launch a poll
with a few questions for you to answer
that will check your understanding of
cdes so far and you can also follow
along with these on your handouts under
the check your understanding section
so I'll give you a minute to answer
those and then we'll review them
together
okay Brittany let's go ahead and close
the poll
and view those responses thank you so
yeah you should be able to see
everybody's responses on the screen now
and we will go over these together
um so what can you find in the cder and
the answer is CDs and forms we're going
to look at examples of both and how to
find those today
question number two
endorsed cdes have been reviewed and
approved by the NIH so those are
designated as endorsed
and finally question number three to
identify an endorsed CDE you want to
look for the gold ribbon and don't worry
we're going to look at lots of endorsed
cdes today so you will definitely be
able to identify those by the end of
today's training
all right so thank you for participating
in that poll
foreign
to see if anyone has any questions so
I'm going to pause here
um Brittany have we had any questions
come in that Robin or I can address
we had a couple of questions come in
um the first one for Robin can you say
forms are part of CDE
or do forums use CDE
hi I saw that and it's the latter
um formed new CDE so you can think of
cdes as being the individual questions
or variables or those are like alternate
names you could sometimes call them and
a form is a curated set of um of cdes so
forms used CDs hope that clears it up
for you
and we have another question also for
Robin from Corey
um where is the repository I.E where is
the data stored
so that's a great question this is a
different kind of repository this is a
repository of common data elements so
what we have here are the cdes the
variables that you can use in research
we are not actually a data repository so
we do not store any research data in
this repository
um so what we have here are are
different kinds of variables that are
hopefully going to be reused across
multiple studies to make those data more
interoperable Downstream and that's what
we are storing and I hope that helps
and we have another question from
Catherine
um is there a relationship between cdes
and data standards
yes I mean cdes are I mean in a way they
can be a type of standard especially if
a you know a group of research
initiative mandates that their
researchers all use a certain set of
cdes and that becomes the standard for
that project in a distance many cpes are
are linked to a broader data standards
you'll see if you start exploring the
repository
um you'll see that some of them are
linked to standard terminologies like
link and snomed and um
yeah
we're going to take another question
um from n High
it sounds like a CDE is a standardized
question and answer so both the question
and answer must be present not just the
question is that right
uh very close so the question and the
answer and the answer is sometimes it's
an answer list like it's a standardized
list of what we call permissible values
like answers that are allowed but it
might also be a format so it might be a
question and there's no answer list to
choose from but the answer might have to
be a number for instance or it might be
text or a date
okay
okay and that's all the questions for
now um we've had a couple more come in
that we will take later on
great thank you for those questions
everyone and thank you uh Brittany and
Robin
um yes please keep your questions coming
we'll try to answer as many as we can
today and I'll pause a few more times
throughout to answer those
okay so we are now ready to search the
repository if you'd like you can follow
along with my demonstration on your own
device Kate is putting a link in the
chat to the Repository
I will try to make the screen bigger
when I can um but you can also adjust
the size of the demonstration on your
own screen by going to the view options
at the top and adjusting the zoom ratio
okay so I will open up the repository
now
we will Dive In
okay so anyone can search the cder and
see results for cdes and forms but to
access all of the repositories features
you'll need a unified medical language
system terminology service account or
UTS account
so you'll see the sign in button in the
repositories upper right corner to
either sign into an existing account or
sign up for a new one I'm already signed
in so my profile name appears there if
you don't have an account I encourage
you to wait until after this training to
sign up you can still follow along on
your own device and see almost
everything and as we go I'll point out
any differences between what the
repository looks like when you are or
aren't signed in
if you do have a UTS account feel free
to take a moment and sign in
next I'm going to point out some
features of the repositories home page
so the default search is for NIH
endorsed cdes and you can switch to
searching for all cdes or forms by
clicking on the tabs above the search
box you can search with a topic a
keyword or an organization name
you can also select cdes or forms from
the menu across the top of the page to
search or browse either type and we'll
look at how to browse a little bit later
so let's start with searching within NIH
and door cdes using keywords
currently there are
125 NIH endorsed cdes that come from the
project 5 collection which were
developed for a wide spectrum of
covid-19 research including
translational clinical and applied
research
so let's imagine that you're designing a
research study and you want to collect
data about the medications that a
patient being treated for covid-19
receives
we can search within the endorsed group
with the keyword medications to see if
any cdes are available on that topic
so I will type medications into the
search box and then click the magnifying
glass or hit enter on the keyboard to
search
I will make my screen a little bigger
so here are the results
and I'm going to point out some features
of the results page now
notice the yellow ribbon that indicates
a CDE is NIH endorsed
also on the results page you can see the
CDE title it's stored
who it's used by and a preview of the
permissible responses if they're
available
every CDE has a stored which is the
organization or project that owns the
CDE so if this CDE ever needs an update
or it changes in any way the steward is
responsible for working with the
repository to make those updates
and that's the answer to number five on
your handout
if the CDE ever needs an update or
changes in any way the steward is
responsible for working with the
repository to make those updates
typically distort is also who is the CDE
is used by although anyone can use it
below the title of the CDE is its
definition which is a short description
of its purpose
and the definition is helpful for
determining if a CDE fits your topic
some CDE definitions also include
information about their development
click on the second one in our list
titled covid-19 specific medication type
so we can see its full record
all right so this is the record for the
CDE
at the top we see a lot of the same
information that we saw on the results
page like it's stored and who it's used
by in its definition
if you'll recall our definition of CDE
earlier it should have a precisely
defined question and a set of specific
allowable responses and we need to
scroll down to see those
so I'm going to scroll
and the first thing I come to are the
permissible values we're going to come
back to those in a moment because if you
keep scrolling
you'll see this naming section
and this section includes the preferred
question text for the CDE
so in this case it is what medications
did the patient take
to treat covid-19
that is the precisely defined question
the permissible values are the specific
allowable responses to that question so
if I scroll back up we can take a look
at those
they're arranged at a table so let's
review each part of the table
the first column in the table is labeled
value and it includes the allowable
answers to the question
so in other words this is the specific
data that is being collected and these
are the responses that someone answering
the question can choose from
the next four columns are related to the
code including code name code Code
system and code description
by default The Code system is the NCI at
thesaurus but you can change to
different code systems by selecting the
boxes beside them
and the system options include link NCI
thesaurus snomed ctus and umls
uh you should be aware that if you're
not logged into a UTS account then the
permissible's values section might be
missing some information
if you keep scrolling down the record of
the CDE you're going to see a lot more
details about it we don't have time to
explore all of this in depth today so
I'll refer you to the repository help
guide for more information and Kate is
putting a link to the help guide in the
chat
foreign
let's try out searching
um so I have an exercise for you on the
screen I'd like you to search within the
NIH endorsed DDE collection for a CDE
that collects employment status of the
respondent
and once you've found it give me a
thumbs up
with the reactions button
I'm already seeing some thoughts for
however everybody a second
to do that search
wonderful all right lots of thumbs so
now let me know in the chat one of the
permissible values for that CDE
the what is one of the permissible
values listed with the CDE that you just
found
great the answers are rolling in
there's quite a few permissible values
to choose from with this one
right
okay thank you
for completing that exercise I'm gonna
review so we can all take a look at how
we found that together
so I'll open the repository back up
and I'm going to go back to the top of
the screen and click on the repository
logo so I can start fresh with a new
search
okay so I'll start by searching within
the NIH endorsed cde's search box for
employment status
I'll search
and this is giving me four results
based on the definition of the first one
which is a textual description of a
person's employment status
I think that sounds like a pretty good
fit so I'm going to click on the title
to see its full record and I'll scroll
down to permissible values
and view the different allowable
responses that are listed in that value
column so I think between everybody we
listed them all but as you can see there
are quite a few different options here
like working without pay employed
full-time employed part-time
Etc
great thank you
okay so next we are going to explore
searching for all cdes in the repository
so you'll recall that the repository has
over 29 000 cdes and 125 of them are NIH
endorsed for now and that number number
will grow so you might want to search
outside of the endorsed group for
certain topics
so I'm going to return to the repository
homepage
and
on this home page I will click on the
search all cdes tab from above the
search box so that we can search the
entire CDE collection
okay this time I want to find cdes that
measure a person's physical activity
so I will type physical
activity into the search box
and search
and I get a lot of results almost 400.
and because it's so many results I can
use the filters that are on the left
hand side of the screen to help find
cdes that actually match what I need
the first thing I'm going to do is try
limiting to NIH endorsed cdes
clicking on the box beside NIH endorsed
now when I do that this gives me four
results
but I don't think that any of them are
measuring a person's physical activity
just based on their titles and their
definition
so in that case I will take the NIH
endorsed filter off by clicking on the X
beside that filter name
and now I'm back to my original result
group
so if you can't find an endorsed CDE
that matches what you need there's a few
other criteria that you can use
first you can look at the collections
options
these are the organizations or
initiatives with cdes that are related
to your search so if your organization
is listed there then you might see if it
has any related cpes
so if I click on the nhlbi
to limit to cdes from them
notice now that I have two more
available filters
to specific projects and topics from
within the nhlbi like the sickle cell
disease project
if I want to remove the nhlbi filter
from my search I can just go back up to
the top of my search and click on the X
beside its name and now I'm back to my
original results
the second thing that you can refer to
is the registration status so I will
scroll down a little bit so you can see
that here registration status
this indicates where a CDE or form is in
the review and vetting process
so if you can't find an endorsed CDE
check to see if any standard cdes meet
your criteria a standard registration
means that the CDE might have been
developed by a standards development
organization like link or vetted by some
other recognized Authority
so I'm going to try limiting to standard
Now by clicking on the box beside it
and so that gave me 24 results
and if I just glanced at their titles
they seem to be more related to physical
activity my topic
there's one more way to filter your
results that I want to show you
you can check to see if a CDE is used
with any forms that you're familiar with
or are from a widely recognized survey
or instrument
so remember that forms are sets of cdes
I'm going to show you an easy way to see
if a CDE is a part of any forms
so first you'll click on the CDE that
you're interested in I'm going to choose
the third one in our list titled to what
extent are you able to carry out your
everyday physical activities such as
walking
Etc
click on that
and if I scroll down a little bit
I see a blue button that says linked
forms
and when I click on the linked forms
button
if it appears on any forms I'll see this
pop-up window
and it lists the forms that use the CDE
so here we have two
so if these forms are ones that you're
familiar with then this might be a good
CDE option and I saw somebody give a
nice surprise reaction
um Emoji to that yeah it's a great
feature to use
all right we're going to search uh
specifically for forms in a few minutes
too so you'll see how to how to do that
as well
okay
this is a good time to pause for
questions
um so Brittany have we had some other
questions come in
we have had quite a few questions come
in
um the first one for you Catherine is
from Manuel I want um for the search he
wants to know why is physical activity
bringing those results
oh good question so
um
Pro what and Robin can correct me if I'm
wrong
um but when I type in physical activity
it is searching all of the different
fields in the CDE record for those terms
so if physical or activity or physical
activity is appearing anywhere in that
CDE then it's going to pull that into my
search results which is why those
filters are really helpful
um and Robin if you have more to say
about the search mechanics feel free to
jump in
no I think you're you've got that right
so far and I know we have a lot of
questions too so
okay the next question
um from Lena is there a difference
between the CDE forms and validated
instruments
from Psych tests Etc
that one's for Robin
hi yes so the short answer to that is
that
um all validated instruments in the
repository are forms but not all forms
are validated instruments uh if that
makes sense um that's where you would
find the repository is these two
sections the cdes and the forms and you
would find validated instruments in
within the forums
um that's not to say that we have you
know definitely don't have all the
validated instruments that you might be
looking for you'd have to search and see
if we do but that's where you would find
them
but some forms as Catherine pointed out
are um you know created by groups
they're not particularly validated
instruments but they're sets of cdes
that
um you know sort of belong together and
might be used for research purposes
okay another question also for Robin
from Adam do cdes respect their
principles if yes how do you define
their present identifier
so yeah great cdes do make data more
fair they make it more interoperable
which of course is the i in Fair and
interoperable data is more reusable so
um that's how they help support Fair
data in a very you know putting it very
simply and every cden form in the nihcd
repository has a persistent identifier
it's called the nlm ID and when you're
looking at the details page later
um you'll see that under the identifiers
that that's um that's present on every
page and doesn't change so
okay we have a another question from for
Catherine
um son young wants to know can anyone
open an account to use cder
uh yes you'll just need to sign up for a
UTS account
um and if you go in the repository to
the sign in button in the upper right
hand corner you'll see the different
login uh options and so you can create
an account and then you'll be able to
explore all of those features
and she had a follow-up question how do
you find out who is the steward for the
CDE
sure yes so the storage should be listed
with the CDE right below the title uh
let me just show you here quickly on the
screen so if this is the record for the
CDE then I have Steward listed right
below this title so you should see that
for each of them
okay
um another question for Robin are the
cdes mapped to sdtm
so we they're in the repository we at
nlm on the repository team we don't do
any mapping to sdtm I however I had to
do a quick search
um for sdtm and found a few results
showing me that some CD working groups
that submit their data to us are doing
that um it wasn't a lot but there is
some there
and we're going to take
um one or two more questions before we
move on the next one is from Katie why
is vsac value set and that is for Robin
[Music]
right so our Visa everyone may not be
familiar with it it's the value uh value
set Authority center it's another nlm
product
um which is a tool for uh
creating value sets basically those
those answer lists I was talking about
earlier their list of permissible values
and so
um if you were using a CDE in the
repository or if somebody wanted to put
a CD in a repository and for the answer
list reference one of those value sets
they could do that we do have a link
there
and last question for Robin
um Eileen wants to know why are there
multiple codes and how do you use them
so I think Arlene was talking about
multiple codes and the permissible
values table and those codes as shown
there are concept codes and they help
describe the meaning of that permissible
value so they're codes that come usually
from like the umls or from the NCI
thesaurus and sometimes it will take
more than one code there to help
adequately describe the meaning of the
value
okay um that's all the questions for now
just in the interest of time
great sounds good thank you Brittany
thank you Robin
um yes please keep your questions coming
we will try to answer
um as many as we can today and I'll also
make sure that you know how to get help
to answer any questions we don't address
at the end of this
um training
all right so I'm going to open up the
Repository
and go back to the repository home page
because the next thing we're going to do
is review strategies for when you are
searching for cdes and you're struggling
to find one related to your topic
so let's say you want to view cdes that
measure pain or have to do with pain in
some way
so I'm going to switch to searching for
all cdes by clicking on the search all
cdes tab above my search box
and I'm just going to type pain
into my search box and search
so we get over a thousand results with
this search on the one hand this is
great because it means that we have a
lot of options for finding a relevant
CDE on the other hand that is way too
many results to sort through
um so take a moment to glance at these
results and consider how you might
narrow down these results what are some
filters or other strategies that you
could use to narrow your results down
let me know in the chat one way that you
might narrow these down and think about
some of those strategies we just
reviewed together
oh got some good answers here
um yes someone said additional keywords
we're going to look at that uh Joanne
says NIH gold which I think referring to
NIH endorsed yes we can filter to NIH
endorse cdes
um someone says that we can select the
steward and one thing that we could do
is select the collection so if we want
to limit to the organization or
initiative that we're associated with or
familiar with we can do that
excellent and the other thing is
limiting to standard under registration
status so those are the three
um strategies that we reviewed earlier
together and those are also the answer
to number six on your handout so I'll go
over them again
um so you can limit to NIH endorsed cdes
limit to a specific collection or limit
to standard under registration type
okay so another strategy is to get more
specific with your search by adding
additional terms which somebody
suggested in the chat and that's exactly
right
so for example is there a type of pain
or pain in a specific part of the body
that you're concerned with like a limb
is there a condition or disease that the
pain is associated with such as a
fracture
is there an activity or movement that
you're trying to gauge pain during like
walking
you can add these terms to your search
to see if a more specific CDE is
available
so I'm going to add walking to my search
in the search box at the top of the page
and then I'll click search
and so this retrieves 26 results
so by getting more specific with my
Search terms it really helped me to
narrow my focus and my options
and keep in mind that you can combine
these strategies to further narrow down
your results
okay let's do another search
um maybe I want to find cdes that record
body mass index
so I'm going to go back up to the top of
my results page I'm going to delete my
previous search and this time I'm going
to type in body
mass index so I can search all cdes for
body mass index and I'll click search
so with this I get about 20 results and
in those 20 results you can probably
find what you need
however unlike our previous example with
pain when we got over a thousand results
and we wanted to narrow our Focus we
might want to broaden the search a
little bit to make sure that we're
seeing as many potential cdes as
possible for our topic
so one way to broaden our search is to
consider any alternative terms
abbreviations or acronyms that could be
used for your term so some cdes might
use a different word to describe the
same topic that you're searching for so
what's another term or abbreviation or
acronym that someone could use instead
of body mass index
tell me what you think in the chat could
be an alternative
right yeah BMI I'm already seeing that
from a couple of people yeah so the
acronym BMI is a pretty common acronym
for body mass index so we can try
searching with that as well maybe there
are cdes that use that term
so one way to also search for BMI in
addition to body mass index is to use
the word or to connect the words in the
search box
and this will search the repository for
cdes that contain either term and or is
the answer to number seven on your
handout
so to explore or excuse me to expand
your search add similar terms or
acronyms to your search and connect each
term with or
so I'm going to go back up to my search
box and I already have body mass index
I'm going to type in or mbmi
and then I'll click search
and I went from 22 results to 48. so it
expanded my search when I searched for
both of those terms
another feature that I want to point out
that is useful for finding relevant C
more like this button so I'm going to
click on the first CDE in my list titled
body math index BMI
we can see its full record
and I'm going to scroll down
until I see that familiar linked forms
button that we looked at earlier
beside it is the more like this button
and when I click on that a window opens
showing the cdes that are similar to the
one that I'm viewing so this is a great
feature if you find a CDE that's on your
topic but it's not quite what you need
and you want to see similar options and
this is number eight on your handout
click on the more like this button to
see similar cdes or forms to the ones
that you're viewing
okay so now we are going to explore
searching for forms and that works very
similarly to searching for CDs so I'll
go back out to the repository homepage
and this time I'm going to click on the
search forms button above the search box
and let's say that you want to screen
study participants for depression and
you specifically want to use nida's
self-administered version of the Prime
MD tool
you can use the information that you
have about that tool to try and find it
in the Repository
so I'm going to type into my search box
Nida
[Music]
Prime MD
and I'll search
this gives me one result so I'm going to
click on the title to view its details
and confirm that this is the form that
I'm looking for
so right away I see our form at the top
of the record
below that
I want to draw your attention to the
description section
the first sentence of the description
reads the patient Health questionnaire
phq is a self-administered version of
the Prime MD tool for common mental
health disorders administered by health
professionals
and if I keep reading I also see that
this particular form is the phq2 which
compromises the first two items of the
phq-9
so maybe after reading this description
you decide that you want to see the
version with all nine items what would
you search in the repository if you
wanted to see the tool that includes all
nine items what's a keyword that you may
search in the repository let me know
what you think in the chat
yeah exactly lots of folks are getting
it the phq-9
um so we see in the description that
that's what the nine item version is
called so we can try searching for that
and the point is the descriptions can be
really useful for not only making sure
that you found the CDE or the form that
you're looking for but also if there are
similar ones or different versions of
them that you could use for your data
collection
okay so let's try another exercise
this time we'll try looking for a form
so see if you can locate in the
repository the clinical decision support
for substance abuse form that comes from
the Nida
and once you've got it
tell me in the chat how many questions
it has
so again looking for a form
and once you've found it let me know in
the chat how many questions it has I'll
give everybody a minute
wonderful getting lots of responses 28
is the consensus and that's right
um yes this form has 28 questions
included with it
so let's review how to find that
together I'm going to open the
repository back up
there we go and I'm going to go back out
to the home page
and I will click on the search forms tab
and I'll type in clinical
decision
support for substance abuse
and click search and then I see this top
one which the name matches I also see
that the steward is the Nida
and it tells me that there are 28
questions
and I can click on the title to actually
view those 28 questions in the record
great
okay there's one more way to find cdes
and forms in the repository which is
browsing
so I'm gonna go back out to the home
page start fresh
you can use the cdes and forms buttons
from the top of the home page screen to
browse so let's look at forms I'm going
to click on forms from that menu
and from here I'll scroll below the
search box and here are the different
collections with available forms that we
can browse
so let's click on the mic HD
to see what forms they have
so I get 15 forms
and I want to point out that there are
filters for limiting to different
projects within this collection on the
left hand side so if you're looking for
a specific group of forms then you can
look here
and I can click on one of those and then
I see the forms within that specific
project
if you want to browse cdes this process
is the same except I will click on the
CDs button from across the top of the
home page
and then if I scroll down I can see the
different Collections and I can click
into those to browse from there
so let's try browsing together now
I've got a third exercise for you
um what is the name of one of the Nei
CDE collections that you can browse in
the Repository
so we're looking at cdes and we want to
browse and what are the different
collections within the Nei that we can
browse let me know in the chat
great getting a lot of answers here and
give folks another
a couple seconds to take a look
okay great yeah so let's take a look at
how to find those together and I think
lots of folks have gotten the answer in
the chat and we'll just take a look at
how to do that as a group so I'm going
to open the repository back up
and so I am already on the page to
browse cdes
and so what I want to do to find what
collections are within the Nei is scroll
down
and I see Mei I'll click on that
and so now I'm seeing all of the cdes
from the Nei and they have two
collections within the Nei that I can
limit it to so the Lasik quality of life
collaboration project has 126 cdes
and the I Gene has 109 so those are the
two collections that you can then limit
to within an EI
okay great all right so
the final feature that I want to
demonstrate is how to save cdes and
forms that you find so that you can come
back to them later
the CDE the cder has a feature called my
boards where you can create a board
which is kind of like a folder to store
CDs and forms that you need later and my
boards is the answer to number nine on
your handout
in order to save and access boards
you'll need to be logged into your UTS
account
um and like I mentioned at the beginning
of the training you can sign up for a
UTS account if you don't already have
one but you will need it in order to
save cdes and forms and return to them
later
okay so I'm going to go back out to the
home page to walk through using my
boards so once you're signed in
to create and access your boards click
on my boards from the menu across the
top of the page
and it actually signed me out so I'm
just going to pause my share and sign
back in really quick
okay here we go just timed out on me
there all right so again I'm going to
click on my board from across the top of
the page
and when I'm signed in I will then see
the boards that I've created so I have
three here
um notice that one of them in the middle
is her forms and the other two are for
cdes you can't save them to the same
board so you'll need to make separate
boards for each type
I'm gonna select my forms board so you
can see what that looks like
and so here are the different forms that
I've saved to it and it gives me a brief
description of them if those are
available and I can just click on the
title of the form to go view it in the
Repository
I'll go back to my board here one other
thing to show you on the screen
um if you want to delete a form from
your board you just click the little pin
symbol beside its title and that will
unpin it from your board
but what you probably want to see is how
to add them to your rewards um so let's
go back to our search and find some CDs
and forms that we can add to our boards
so I'm just going to do a really quick
search of all cdes for diabetes because
I know that there will be a lot of cdes
on that topic
and when I find a CDE in the results
list that I want to add to a board I can
just click on the little pin beside its
name
and when I click on that little pin
It'll ask me which board do you want to
add it to and then I can click on the
board I want to add it to and it will
add it
I'll do that again
click on the board I want to add it to
and then it'll tell me that it's been
pinned to that
you can also click into a CDE so
view its entire record and then select
add to board and you'll get the same
pop-up window and from there you can
click the board that you want to add it
to
and forms can be saved in the exact same
way
okay
I bet we've got some more questions so I
think it's a good time before we wrap up
Brittany have any more questions come in
we have quite a few
um the first question is from song Young
is there a is there any CDE that is more
relevant to basic science researchers
that owns for Catherine
so I think actually I may need Robin's
help answering that question if there
are I think the question is that there
are collections related to basic science
and that is a great question I don't I
don't have a quick answer for you I'm
afraid
um
yeah that's all I can say right now
I can't think of off the top of my head
of any particular collections that are
aimed at basic science so
you might have to explore a bit
browsing might be a good way to kind of
take a look at what is available and
seeing the collections and the projects
and initiatives within collections might
be a good starting point for that
okay
um so we have another question also from
Young if stewards need to update cdes do
they simply log in and have the edit
option then
[Music]
I can take that one that used to be the
case
um but since the new governance policies
and procedures were created just like I
mean this last year I guess when we
really started them
um the answer now is no because
everything that's going to get published
from here on out in the repository has
to go through the endorsement process
and once it's been endorsed the stewards
are not allowed to log in and make any
changes those changes would have to go
back through the governance committee
and be approved
and the next question is for Robin
um Adam wants to know what if you choose
onc it shows birth date as an option any
idea why is that
I think that was during a search
exercise that Catherine did and I
can no longer remember what was
happening on screen during that
Catherine do you know
oh let me take a look I might be able to
come back to that question Brittany let
me take a look at yeah
okay the next question from Nancy having
a wide range of cdes for the same
precise concept sort of defeats the
purpose of common doesn't it does NIH
endorsements take into account the
overlap with other indoor cdes
and that I will take that and um so yes
absolutely NIH endorsement definitely
takes into account overlap
um we the aim of course is in it's in
the name it's in common we want things
to be reused as much as possible so that
they are common to many many studies and
makes that data that much more
interoperable so sometimes you may see
multiple cdes about the same topic or
domain if you see multiple endorsed cdes
about the same topic or domain there are
probably some subtle but key differences
in there and what's being captured or
measured so I think somebody in a
previous training gave the example of
employment status there are several cdes
about unemployment status but they're
all kind of they're coming at it from
different angles or they have different
possible answers and so that's what
difference differentiates them and we
are working towards a way of grouping
these similar ones so you can um you
know pull up ones that are are similar
but not identical and and compare them
and see which is best for your purposes
and um while I'm talking about
endorsement I saw there were a couple
other quick questions
um somebody asked why the promise
measures are not NIH endorsed and the
answer to that is that the endorsement
process is relatively new and it does
require that CD working groups submit
their data in a particular format so we
do hope that promise and other NIH
groups will all choose to submit their
cdes for endorsement and that will
eventually be published in the
repository but it just you know just
hasn't happened yet
and
um somebody also asked if we endorsed if
the nicbe governance committee endorses
cdes that are not validated the answer
is that they would prefer that cdes be
validated but it's we're also it's
understood that famous things especially
like with covid-19 for example
um a lot of the you know the CDs that
were arising for Houston studies about
Copa 19 were so new
um that they couldn't possibly be
validated yet so
um you know they do take that into
account as well
okay and the next question is for
Catherine
um does the order of Search terms matter
no the order of your Search terms should
not matter
um I do want to point something else out
uh we had talked earlier about when you
search for example physical activity uh
what is being searched and it's each of
the different fields of that CDE record
you can put a phrase in quotations in
quotation marks and that will search for
the exact phrase so that's another
strategy that you could try as well
I'm gonna jump in sorry I'm gonna jump
in and just add one comment to that
um then the order of your Search terms
should not change the number of results
that you're getting if it's the same
terms but it may affect the relevancy
rankings of those results so for
instance I put a search for birth date
and then date birth and I got same
number of results both times but there
were different results on top because
the order it does matter a little bit to
the algorithm
great thank you Robin
um and the next question for Catherine
can you download The Forum questions
yes you can download the form questions
uh from Once you
um either from the record or you from
your board uh and I think on the help
guide which I believe Kate share a link
to that earlier maybe we can put that
back in the chat there are directions
for the different ways to export uh
forms and and cdes out of the Repository
okay
and we have a another question from sung
young what is the difference between
linked forms and more like this
um clarification CDE seems mostly for
clinical researchers
I can answer the question about the
different buttons um good questions so
linked forms is going to show different
forms that a CDE is a part of so if
you're looking at a CDE and you click
linked forms it's going to show you is
it a part of any forms same if a form is
within another form
um the more like this button is going to
show similar cdes so are they about a
certain kind of topic or a similar topic
so that's the difference between those
Robin may be better equipped to address
the other part of that question
no I think I mean I think she's answered
it or I'm sorry they I don't know they
have answered it themselves um
the uh yeah the cdes in the repository
are mostly for clinical researchers
that's true and that's why I was having
trouble thinking of examples of basic
science ones earlier because I'm I'm not
aware of any collections off the top of
my head for basic science
um if stewards need to update cdes do
they simply log in and have the edit
option then
um that's a follow-up
I think we oh is that a follow-up to the
answer I gave earlier I see that so
they're asking if they could log in and
then have that change be reviewed by the
governance committee
um that's not the workflow right now
I'll just say that we're working on our
workflow so it doesn't work quite that
way yet
okay
and I believe that's all the questions
as of right now
um if anybody has any questions please
put them in the chat
great thanks Brittany okay so to wrap up
I want to oops
well goodness gracious let me just get
my slides back in order okay there we go
um so to wrap up I do want to point out
a couple ways that you can get help with
the repository so at the top of the
repository is the help menu and if you
hover over that you'll see a guides page
which provides in-depth instructions for
using the repository
um and we've shared the link to that a
couple times uh keep an eye on the new
features page for any updates and you
can also use the contact us button to
write to the nlm help desk with your
questions
um I will ask Kate to put the handout
answer key in the chat so that you have
that answer key to take with you in case
you missed any of those and to use for
your review
um thank you for attending today's
session we are also putting a link in
the chat to an evaluation survey and
would appreciate you letting us know how
we can improve our training in the
future at the end of the survey you will
see a screen that will allow you to get
an enrollment code that you need and
instructions on how to obtain your MLA
CE if you're doing that today so we do
appreciate you filling out that
evaluation and the link is in the chat
now and thank you so much for attending
today's session and we hope to see you
at future nlm webinars